[Musica]
bene oltre sessant'anni che ci occupiamo
delle competenze dei manager e dei capi
quando parlo di capi parlo di capi
gerarchici a qualsiasi livello
dall'operaio al presidente sono stati
scritti centinaia di libri migliaia di
pubblicazioni più o meno scientifiche
penso che chiunque sia un manager o
lavori non abbia seguito a un corso
sulla lira si sul manager su come
gestire le persone ma quindi la domanda
è ma come mai oggi ci troviamo qui nel
2018 ancora parlare di queste cose
bene la risposta mi è venuto immediata
minuti immediato purtroppo devo dire
guardando dei dati che sono devastanti
il gatto devastante questo ricerca su
fonte molto credibile gallo go 2017
campione assolutamente enorme in tutto
il mondo
87 per cento dei collaboratori e design
gage disengagement [ __ ] più che
demotivato più che demotivato significa
che alla gentile domanda consiglieresti
il tuo capo come una persona con la
quale lavorare insieme
la risposta che nove persone su dieci
hanno dato è anche no grazie
e questo ovviamente ci fa capire che ci
sono dei problemi che questi
sessant'anni comunque non sono stati
buttati via non si butta mai via niente
però evidentemente ci sono dei problemi
questi problemi non vorrei dire da dove
nascono ma questi problemi ci fanno
sviluppare un po un concetto di
reinventare il management ho gradito
molto
l'inizio sull'innovazione perché noi
sappiamo che le aziende nov hanno
tantissimo prodotti servizi processi
peccato che non innovano mai quello che
noi chiamiamo il modello di management
beh sono tanto il modello di business a
come fare il business come fare i soldi
ma poco come gestire bene le persone
detto questo bisogna rinventa re
management il manager più o meno dove
nasce ma più o meno nei 150 anni fa
qualche pioniero del management e
l'orgoglio olg albright lo stesso fuori
qui vedete un po di immagini hanno
costruito quello che sono i sistemi
processi le strutture le gerarchie le
linee di comando che sono tuttora
utilizzate valide in molte aziende non
solo italiane ma a livello
internazionale
ovviamente abbiamo un piccolo problema
il piccolo problema è che sono passati
150 anni e che quindi il mondo è
drammaticamente cambiato questo è quello
che noi chiamiamo il management 1.0 il
fatto che abbiamo una industry 4.0 ci fa
capire il percorso che abbiamo fatto in
questi anni
ovviamente ora le esigenze le conosciamo
tutti bene no sono esigenze di
innovazione di collaborazione
i nostri ragazzi dell'università la cosa
cui danno più valore e il clima
aziendale non è più la sana competizione
interna dove alla prima curva delle due
parole ci si dimentica sane non
competizione si parla di collaborazione
di team
ma da dove voglio con voi come dire
intraprendere questo viaggio veloce di
reinventare il management
ecco io vorrei partire con la stessa
definizione definizioni di management
ecco quando parliamo di management vabbè
si può prendere dalla treccani ha tante
definizioni ora qui non voglio leggervi
tutte le definizioni ma in fondo tutte
le definizioni che ho trovato arrivano
fondamentalmente anno come essenza
ultima il fatto che il manager è colui
che organizza pianifica motiva le
persone le risorse l'obiettivo ultimo
ovviamente è al fare di fare profitto e
di portare a casa i risultati
ora leggendo tutte queste definizioni io
mi chiedo sempre ma qual è in fondo la
cosa che ti resta più scolpita a me la
cosa che resta più scolpita e sentitevi
portare a casa i risultati e cioè quello
che mi resta sempre in mente di tutte
queste definizioni è una relazione causa
effetto che dice
manager tu devi portare a casa i
risultati manager devi fare il profitto
e che io credo che questa relazione sia
fondamentalmente sbagliata e perché è
fondamentalmente sbagliata perché se tu
sei un professional questa relazione
causa effetto è perfetta ma se tu sei un
manager tu non devi portare a casa i
risultati
ecco che a questo punto qualcuno
probabilmente rimane un po perplesso
come jimenez non devono portare a casa i
risultati ecco quindi cosa devono fare
ma devono fare quello per cui sono
pagati e cioè loro devono fare di tutto
perché i loro collaboratori portino a
casa i risultati e quindi vedete che
l'equazione è fondamentalmente sbagliata
perché tu capo non devi concentrarti sul
risultato ma devi concentrarti sui tuoi
collaboratori perché loro portino a casa
il risultato e questo ovviamente fa in
modo come voi sapete bene di aumentare
le deleghe mettere al centro la persona
tutte le aziende hanno frasi no del put
people first people posto volo del
capitale intangibile e tutto
fondamentale e poi tutti tanto devono
portare a casa il risultato
a discapito delle persone quindi penso
che questo percorso per inventare il
management parte proprio da reinventare
la definizione stessa di management
quindi come vedete io qui ho scritto
management 4.0 in realtà non avrei
dovuto scriverlo perché appena scritto
un libro management 3.0 hanno fatto
l'industry 4.0 quindi adesso ci sarà la
industry 5.0
anzi l'hanno già fatta ma detto questo
qual è la definizione e con la
definizione una definizione che mette le
persone al centro e quindi dice ma che
cos'è il management
il management e fare di tutto perché i
miei collaboratori possono lavorare al
meglio e quindi porre il collaboratore
al centro di tutto già questa
definizione ci dà un aiuto ma non può
essere tutto qua
e evidente che c'è qualcos'altro da una
serie di riflessioni di ricerche che il
nostro centro sul cambiamento la lirici
e people management della liuc business
school ha portato avanti emerso una cosa
interessante la cosa interessante è che
noi diciamo abbiamo sempre fatto la
domanda sbagliata alle persone sbagliate
una domanda sbagliata le persone
sbagliate
bene intanto generalmente aki abbiamo
sempre chiesto quali sono le competenze
del capo efficace lo abbiamo sempre
chiesto ai capi ovviamente se tu sei un
capo minimamente scappato io so che qui
tra il pubblico c'è il mio rettore se il
mio rettore se il mio lettore mi dovesse
chiedere quali sono le competenze del
docente efficace
io avendo appena più di vent'anni ci
pensò un attimo perché dico scusa appena
glielo script e lui mi guarda mi dice
quindi tu così devi essere no
quindi tutti i capi cosa hanno fatto non
hanno detto proprio tutte le competenze
ne hanno aggiunti a qualcuna tolta
qualcun'altra e quindi abbiamo sempre
fatto la domanda alla persona sbagliata
oltre che alla persona sbagliata abbiamo
sempre fatto anche la domanda sbagliata
perché la domanda che generalmente si fa
dovunque nelle business core sulle
pubblicazioni anche scientifiche è
quella di chiedere quali sono le
competenze le caratteristiche e gli
skill del capo efficace ed ecco che le
persone generalmente rispondono la
classica e devi motivare le due persone
domanda ma come si fa a motivare le
persone allora la seconda è devi essere
un bravo coach uno riesce dice vabbè
adesso farò il bravo coach qualcun altro
gli ha detto no core ci devi essere un
grande evento
lui esce dice vabbè adesso farò il
mentor quindi lui fondamentalmente non
ha mai capito quello che deve fare
ed ecco perché non lo fa col 87 per
cento di depressi
quindi abbiamo sempre fatto la domanda
sbagliata scusate alle persone sbagliate
e cioè il cliente di ogni capo è il
collaboratore
quindi la domanda non va fatta il capo
ma va fatta il collaboratore e cioè
collaboratore cosa deve fare il tuo capo
per permettere a te di lavorare al
meglio il verbo magico e fare noi
abbiamo stiamo portando avanti questa
ricerca tra l'altro chi volesse ancora
sul nostro sito della liuc e abbiamo
intervistato finora mille collaboratori
ai quali ovviamente per coerenza abbiamo
fatto questa domanda e voglio
presentarvi i primi risultati che sono
emersi e quindi diciamo un empoli pronto
view cioè cosa ne pensano i
collaboratori di che cosa i capi
dovrebbero fare per permettere a loro di
lavorare al loro meglio
vediamo che cosa è emerso io mi scuso
sono motociclista e quindi qualcuno mi
ha detto che cosa m ha detto la mt si
ride
devo dire che mi ha ricercatori sono
tutti i giorni ma guardando che cosa
professore ha detto metti quei due che
vanno in moto sull'early dance il 50
5,74 per cento non va in moto non dice
che il capo dovrebbe andare in moto ma
per ora dice quello che fondamentalmente
è easy rider
non so chi di me chi come me se lo
ricorda e porsche ri nato libero ma nato
libero significa capo ogni una volta che
abbiamo definito gli obiettivi
lasciami lavorare non continuare a
interferire e mettere il naso nel mio
lavoro continuando a dire come devo fare
il come è compito del collaboratore la
seconda di importanza è tutta una
cluster rivolta alla comunicazione
all'ascolto fondamentalmente basata
anche sul feedback e i collaboratori
dicono il mio capo non mi da febbre non
mi da fibe significa la cosa più bella
del mondo che non costa niente hai fatto
un buon lavoro
ok oppure senti aspetta un attimo vieni
qua ci parliamo perché c'è qualcosa che
non funziona quindi i capi non lo fanno
non lo fanno lo sappiamo per mille
motivi io mi sono sentito dire di tutto
dopo si offende ci resta male delirio
totale quindi c'è un altro aspetto che
il terzo di importanza che è capo devi
decidere i collaboratori dicono il capo
che non prende le decisioni
ovviamente difficili e un capo che fa
fare tanta fatica perché finché il capo
non decide tutti sono fermi quarto non
meno di importanza se volete questo è un
po never green è concordare col mio capo
gli obiettivi quindi su che cosa io sarò
valutato quest'anno che siano sia di
comportamento che di risultato quindi se
dermico il mio capo e discutere in
questo caso io direi parte il
collaboratore con le sue idee si discute
ultima è come dire è qualcosa che ci
tocca da quando abbiamo come dico io
quattro anni a quando non si può fare
che si metterà nella bara io ho un
nipotino che appena lo metto in macchina
inizia e perché zio e perché perché
perché è perché i collaboratori dicono
capo non puoi chiedermi passione
innovazione valore aggiunto se non mi
spieghi come il mio compito si inquadra
in qualcosa di più ampio in qualcosa che
deve essere uno scopo una missione che
mi permette quindi di dare l'anima
vorrei concludere con due citazioni una
kia si era scatenato grande scalpore
questi uno dei più grandi imprenditori
che ha iniziato la sua convention piena
di clienti dicendo first customer second
che fondamentalmente fa rima con quanto
dice brunson il modo col quale
tratterete i vostri collaboratori è
esattamente in modo col quale loro
tratteranno i vostri clienti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]